una salida en una situación frágil
fallece al cerrar anunció su intención
de renunciar como primer ministro del
gobierno de acuerdo nacional reconocido
por la onu y con base en trípoli
declaró mi sincero deseo de entregar mis
funciones a una próxima autoridad
ejecutiva a más tardar a finales de
octubre
a principios de mes las facciones
rivales de libia acordaron celebrar
elecciones y formar un nuevo gobierno
dentro de los próximos 18 meses en un
discurso televisado al ser expuso eso
como ejemplo de los progresos en los
esfuerzos para unificar el país pero
advirtió las dificultades para lograr
ese objetivo los coreanos en una
cantidad según usted el panorama
político y social ha estado y sigue
polarizado esto derivó en que todos los
intentos de llegar a una solución
pacífica que nos permita acabar con el
derramamiento de sangre y proteger
nuestra fibra nacional que amenaza con
descargarse aún más sean tediosos y
extremadamente difíciles
el deterioro de las condiciones de vida
como resultado de la guerra civil ha
llevado a protestas en ciudades
controladas por ambos bandos en las
últimas semanas los disturbios ya habían
causado tensión dentro del gn antes de
que al cerrarse anunciara su intención
de irse las protestas provocaron que el
gobierno del este a línea do con el
comandante jalifa haftar renunciara el
domingo ambos hechos complican las cosas
para la onu que ha estado mediando en
los últimos diálogos entre las dos
partes en un intento por liberar a libia
de la agitación por la que ha estado
pasando desde el levantamiento de 2011